Hello everyone.
Welcome to toxic Google.
I'm Kevin Belk and today we welcome the cast and creative team behind Disney's
Zootopia.
So first I'd like to welcome Byron Howard,
director
and director of rich more producer Clark Spencer,
Jennifer Goodwin,
Katie Lowe's,
Tommy Chong,
and made Torrance our voice.
How are you guys?
Welcome guys.
It's a cavalcade of stars.
Welcome to [inaudible].
Thank you.
And so thank you guys so much for being here today.
Uh,
obviously we're talking about Disney's latest animated films,
Utopia.
And so Byron and rich,
you guys directed the film.
Can you just talk about us about what the story was and,
and the genesis of this
shower?
Did it all start it all begin?
Well,
okay.
So five years ago after I finished directing tangled with Nathan Greno,
um,
John asked what I wanted to do next.
And what do you do when you pitch to John Lasseter is he doesn't want you to
just pitch one idea.
You want to get an idea of what your interests are and what you're passionate
about.
So Nathan I think pitched six different ideas.
And one thing that all those six ideas had in common was this idea of
anthropomorphic animals,
which are animals that walk up,
right and wear clothes and you cell phones.
And he got so excited about the idea that he literally hugged me and picked me
up off the ground and lifted me into the air.
Like Baby Simba.
He's very strong,
strong man,
a mighty man.
So we knew we had something that John was interested in and cause he grew up on
wind in the willows,
which is a film from the forties or 50s and I grew up on Robin Hood and I think
rich,
your first room on the jungle book talk a book.
That's right.
So we knew we had this great Disney legacy to build on,
but we didn't want him to do something completely new.
So we did a year of research including going to Africa.
No kidding.
They sent us to Africa with 15 of our leadership to do research and nearly get
eaten.
Our cinematographer.
Oh Katie.
Shit.
It got,
you have have to go to Africa.
Yeah.
Above these are guys,
but smells.
Yeah.
Our cinematographer got bitten by multiple animals,
including like a zebra and an ostrich.
And it's a cheeto talent by a cheetah.
Yeah.
Well we care about your entertainment.
That's why our lives all the lines to bring you comedy and hearts.
That's right.
And so rich,
when did you come onto the project because you were probably on wreck it,
Ralph when this started?
Um,
yeah,
I was,
wow.
That was five years ago and I was a man.
I'm a member of the story trust at the studio,
uh,
which is,
all our colleagues,
the directors,
a writers and heads of story.
And uh,
we help each other with the,
with our films.
Um,
we're there to support,
uh,
the other director,
the other directors.
And uh,
I had been kind of following this one and there's some that you follow more
intimately than,
than others.
And,
and I had been following this one from the beginning.
Early part.
Yeah.
Back when it was a spy movie.
That's where the story,
it was a spy movie when
we started and we know,
okay.
And so,
so I'd been kind of with this one from the beginning as,
as a support,
you know,
system,
part of the support system.
And there was a moment about a year and a half ago as,
as these movies always have like a bump in the road,
you know,
and uh,
this one was a pretty big one where we wanted to try switching the main
characters are the protagonist because for the longest time,
uh,
nick,
the Fox character,
Jason Bateman's character was the protagonist who's the main character.
Uh,
and the story was just not coming together,
um,
in that way.
So we said,
why don't we try flipping,
you know,
Judy and nick and inlet,
uh,
Judy be kind of our eyes and ears coming into this new world.
And Lo and behold,
the story just kind of laid out,
you know,
at our feet and we're like,
oh great.
You know,
we,
we figured it out,
but oh great.
Now we have to make all these changes,
you know,
and we only have about a year and a half to get this thing finished.
So,
uh,
it was obvious it was a two person job.
Uh,
and John Lasseter said,
could you jump,
you know,
the,
you know the movie pretty well.
Could you jump on with Byron,
you know,
and,
and see it through to the end.
Clark,
does this freak you out as producer when they say,
let's just start over and flip the story around you.
You know,
it's interesting the,
you realize the most important thing is telling a great story.
And so definitely in that moment you think to yourself,
are we really going to be able to turn this around?
But what we try to do when we do it a lot in animations,
we very quickly make a new version of that film.
And I always feel like we have the other version sitting on a shelf over here.
Let's go experiment because we need to know for sure whether this was the right
idea or not.
And when we did it and we turned it around in about six weeks,
you could just see this was the right way to go.
You really fell in love with Jennifer's character right away.
You were rooting for that character,
which is the thing we were struggling with,
with Nick's character.
Cause he's a cynical kind of a character.
It was really easy to get on to Judy side and it just felt like it was right
thing.
So at that moment in time,
you just start working with the team.
How do you please,
can we do it this way?
Please?
Can we have some money in just a few more million?
That's going to be so good.
Just a little mini likes it.
Nate's on board.
Well,
in your wonderful voice cast here.
So,
uh,
Jennifer,
we'll start with you.
Describe your character,
Judy Hopps uh,
is a bunny.
Yes.
And so when were you pulled into it and describe your character?
Um,
when,
when I'm always,
I pulled into,
I was pulled into it,
uh,
to,
I mean it didn't take much pulling.
Yeah.
Cause you're a huge,
you're a huge Disney fan,
right?
It isn't a file.
Yes.
Um,
I mean d by The way,
this is a true story of my getting cast.
I was in Mickey Mouse Pajamas and I was pregnant with my first and it was in my
kitchen and I had a message from all of my agents,
including my voice over agent.
And I thought I was being fired from a different job
cause I just assumed and I'm not actually,
I'm actually a really like,
you know,
fiercely optimistic person,
like the character Judy hops.
But I was just sure that,
why would everyone call me at once unless they were trying to like soften the
blow.
And so I,
and my Mickey Mouse Pajamas,
I turned to my husband and I said,
oh,
I'm getting fired from this other job.
And he said,
or I swear this happened.
He goes,
or Disney's calling to offer you the lead in their next day and made a future.
And I was like,
that's mean,
why don't you had to be like,
I'm obviously
you getting fired and I need support and Kleenex.
And so I picked up the phone and I think goodness got everyone on the phone at
once and they said,
Disney's calling to offer you.
And I lost it for obviously positive reasons.
And I said,
I'll take it.
And they're like,
don't you want to know what the job is?
And I was like,
no,
I want this to be legally binding.
So just call them and say I'm in and then you can call me back and tell me what
it is.
Um,
so yeah,
cause it's a dream come true.
And I didn't stop crying for like a day,
but um,
that was like,
I mean,
I was pregnant with my first kid,
so that was like two and a half years ago with this wild.
Yeah.
And uh,
the character,
Judy hops is a bunny on the police force of Utb.
She's the first Benny she's bought,
been brought in by a,
um,
an integrative mammal initiative.
And uh,
she,
she takes her job seriously.
She does not take herself seriously,
but she is,
she's a bit self righteous,
which I appreciate about her.
She's,
like I said,
she's fiercely optimistic.
She's idealistic.
She believes anyone can be anything that like,
like my dream was to be in a Disney and made a feature.
Hers was to be a bunny cop and a and a on a forceful of predators.
And uh,
she moves to Zootopia from the outskirts called bunny borough.
she is faced with the reality that not everyone,
not only does everyone not live in the peace and harmony,
she assumed Zootopia was,
uh,
but,
but not everyone is even really looking to.
Okay.
And were you excited when they start,
when they decide to switch to the main,
when they said you are now going to be the star of the movie?
I Wa I wasn't upset about it.
Did you call Jason Up?
But I did know but I did win.
I don't think I told you guys this,
but when they did tell me,
cause there was a for,
they came up to Vancouver where I shoot a series once upon a time and um,
when I couldn't come down to La to record these guys and a couple others were
always very generous,
would come visit me in Canada and we've required up there and there was a day we
were like standing in the lobby going in and I asked how screening was going and
one of you said like,
oh no one told you.
And I was like,
told me what they were like we rewrote the movie and like you've got some more
work to do.
And I had to like not jump up and down cause like who doesn't want to be told?
Like,
cause I was having the time of my life like you're going to do this a whole lot
more.
And um,
I,
but I actually called my represent,
I called my agents to be like,
you call,
make sure that they weren't tasting.
It's like,
do I get a raise
illegally by binding?
Yeah.
And then Katie,
he was what I found amazing,
which I didn't know was the extra.
You've been in a lot of Disney movies,
like hero six,
record Ralph frozen feet.
And so now you play doctor honeybadger.
Yes.
Right.
I um,
I was brought into the Disney family a while ago before scandal.
My husband,
it's take your husband to work day today because we're at Google and my
husband's so pumped about it.
Hi Adam.
And so about maybe like seven or eight years ago,
I'm,
I'm a waitress.
I'm a babysitter,
I'm a caterer.
I'm all these jobs.
And my friend worked at Disney and she asked if my husband and I would like to
come into Disney once a week and just do improv games that we would play in
acting school for a bunch of different animators at Disney.
And we did that for about two years and we kind of got into the Disney family,
thank God through that.
And um,
slowly but surely I was able to meet Clark and rich and Byron and um,
and you know,
a lot of different people.
And that's how I ended up auditioning and working and getting apart in a frozen,
another part in wreck it Ralph and then this part in Zootopia.
And so I feel really lucky because it's like the best,
coolest family plays to work like ever.
So um,
that's,
yeah,
amazing because she's with this like very early on when we're developing
characters and she'll do,
she'll do scratch dialog for,
for lots of different characters.
And because to have like these guys in all the time,
I mean we would,
we would burn out or actors if,
if they're in there for every line that they need to deliver as we're making the
movie.
And Katie's really,
really great at helping us develop the characters.
You forget I take,
they also wasn't I was I at the first table read for this.
Wait,
no you were yeah,
no,
you were known,
right.
Nate and Katie,
I think you guys are the ones in the cast.
You really stuck from the very well cause we do table reads.
Once we have a first draft of the script that everyone feels pretty comfortable
about,
we'll sit down and we'll hire,
hire real actors,
real talented actors,
not just us to come in and read the script through.
And the hope with that is that you're going to discover a couple people who
actually stick.
And these guys,
a Nate was there as claw houser and he definitely,
definitely stuck in a big way.
We loved him.
And then Katie,
it was amazing.
And so,
and that's,
that's the way,
even with what you did with Ralph was that you had,
I think you had a,
uh,
Sarah didn't you?
Did Ya?
Yeah.
Sarah and John and,
and uh,
Jack and Jane,
they were all there.
Yeah,
yeah.
No,
it's,
it's a great,
you know,
first opportunity to hear the voices of the characters to field.
I'm kind of coming to life off the page.
Um,
I consider it like a,
we talk about screenings that we do,
uh,
with the films.
I consider like the table read like a first screening almost,
you know,
just without the pictures.
And John and ed can tell too,
like our,
our bosses,
they were like when they heard her,
oh my God,
you got to keep that guy.
Oh,
he's so funny.
And they're,
is he the guy in the Volkswagen
commercial?
Do you remember his Volkswagen commercial where he takes a test drive and he
starts laughing like crazy because when I first heard about Nate,
Jamie,
our casting director said,
you know who'd be great for Hauser is did you ever seen that Volkswagen course
where that guy just last the ass.
I wasn't like,
Oh my God,
you've got to get that guy.
And so we can get him.
I know that's the thing.
Like we made all our,
we make our lists for these,
uh,
these characters who make our top picks for,
we go through actors and actresses and we look and we kind of make our wishlist
like a Christmas list for directors.
And the weird thing is that we got all our top picks on this movie.
So when we were at the Hollywood premiere like two weeks ago and saw these guys
assembled as a group,
that was surreal for us because it is such a powerhouse acting troupe.
It's just,
it's amazing.
Well then we'll go into Nate and then come back to you Italian.
But Nate,
I mean your character's awesome.
Oh
he is a cheetah.
And just tell us about the character and his obsession with she cures.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I play officer call Hauser who ends up,
I'm a,
I'm the
receptionist in the ZPD,
which is where Judy hops is,
is going to,
you know,
start work.
So I kind of become one of maybe her first friends.
The funny,
the crazy thing is,
is in the first table reads,
I was one of Nick's best friends and then that happened.
That's what's always so crazy to watch the story,
you know,
change.
But yeah,
so I get to be her biggest fan.
And then also Gizelle's biggest finch,
Kira Shay.
That's what's kind of funny.
I remember,
I remember
like that was always like in the storyline that was obsessed with this pop
princess.
And it was so fun to be on.
I wonder who it's going to be.
It wasn't going to be good.
They're going to get though.
I have lucky with Shakira.
I'll say it again.
What was it like meeting her at the premiere?
Did you hear what I did?
Oh,
hi.
Clouser Nate literally did that.
I introduced myself as Clauser.
Yeah,
Nice.
Tommy,
you play a JAKKS and so tell your character is ridiculous.
And I love it.
I love it so much.
It was kind of weird,
you know,
when the,
uh,
I got asked to be in a Disney movie.
Yes.
And then I didn't have to guess what kind of character I'd be playing
and noted for one.
And uh,
he cracked me up.
But the thing is with Disney and
I got offered a role in lion king and I turned it down.
I got kicked out a Disney park
and obscene tee shirt.
All is forgiven,
right?
Well,
it's a new generation
without dope,
you know,
can,
you can,
uh,
rich and Byron,
there's no segue.
A rich and Byron.
Uh,
can you talk about just the casting of these guys and finding
Jennifer and was it all,
we have this crazy idea,
let's do this,
or you heard that voice all,
let's write a character for that?
Well,
it's,
we,
we really worked from archetypes.
When we look at the,
our,
our cast,
you know,
we or our characters,
we needed a fiercely determined bunny,
you know,
and a sly,
charming Fox,
you know,
and they have to kind of work beyond the opposite ends of the scale.
Um,
and the way that Byron and I like to work is just putting up like photos of
people or characters or images of,
of characters like that,
like comparable,
you know,
people and,
and actors will just kind of bubble out of those photos,
you know.
And like Byron said,
uh,
Jennifer and Jason were our first picks,
you know,
for,
for Nick and Judy,
you know,
and,
and we look for not just the quality of voice or,
or how they sound or,
uh,
how they deliver lines,
but it's the chemistry between them.
And that's,
that's why we also will record together.
And when we can.
Yeah.
And it's,
I think it's really tough.
I think these guys don't get enough appreciation.
People who do voice acting because a lot of actors and actresses can't do it
because I mean it's,
it's one thing to be photogenic and you know,
kind of a nice on camera,
but when you're in a room by yourself and we're asking you to emote or make
someone laugh or cry,
Jennifer as this crazy scene in the film where she breaks down and it's very
genuine and not everyone can muster that emotion.
And so,
and it's even to be funny like Nate and uh,
Tommy and Katie,
I just,
there's something about that.
There's an extra layer of talent that don't think people appreciate cause we do,
we listen to a lot of people honestly for like for a Rapunzel for example,
we listened to 300 actresses for Rapunzel's role and 150 for Flynn.
And this,
this day,
this film is a little different because we kind of knew who we wanted to go
after.
And so we kind of made the,
that sort of wishlist.
But it's incredible to see like how many people out there just to kind of lack
what these guys have in in spades.
Is it system?
It's an amazing,
right.
And can we talk about the environments because the environments are incredible
and collect.
Can I bring you into this in terms of w w you probably regulated that cause it's
insane.
I think the world's just keep getting bigger and bigger with Disney when you had
it,
you know,
you see big hero six and year flying over,
a San Francisco Kyo and it's just,
it's beautiful and amazing.
And I was like,
oh my gosh.
And you see frozen than with the frozen world and everything with,
with the snow.
And then with this,
I mean you have Sahara Square,
Tundra town,
rainforest district,
little area and bunny burrow.
So can you just talk
about dealing with that since it,
a lot of environment,
that cost difference.
There were a lot of production people gritting their teeth,
you know,
and they heard about this world,
it's always hard,
but we start with the world.
It's interesting.
Jon laster always says,
you got to take the audience to place.
I'd never been before.
So even sometimes before we think too deeply about story,
we think about the world and I think early on Byron and Jared and rich were
really thinking about how do we do a movie like a talking animal movie,
like no one's seen before.
And they came up with this idea that the animal should all live and their
different districts like the cold weather animals live in Tundra town in the hot
weather down in most live in Sahara Square.
And the mice characters live in little retention.
And you started to see what a great world you were building.
Um,
so even though that meant it was going to be huge from that standpoint,
you realize again,
you're really going to support the story in an important way.
And then of course all those characters are going to come together into the
downtown part of Zootopia.
And it really came from research being in Africa and looking at the fact that
there's a watering hole where all the animals come to every day and around that
watering hole.
All of them get along drafts are there with hippos and rhinos and lions and then
they go back to their respective areas,
uh,
after they drink from the water.
And that kind of gave us the idea for the city.
So it is daunting in some ways,
but I think just like working with rich on wreck it Ralph,
it's we have to take the audience to place had never been before.
We have to create something that makes what we're doing in animation and,
and the use of the computers be used to their full capacity.
And I think that's where it's really great to see what the animation community
is doing today.
And they were there even a worlds within the movie that we couldn't include
because it's a 90 minute films so we can only fit so much of the world into what
we're showing you guys.
Cause there were districts that we actually cut out.
We had outback island,
which was an Australian district full of weird animals with pouches and you were
saying it's a good pickpocket joke.
Things like that would have been great.
Maybe next time it would have been fun.
And funny.
And then,
uh,
we always talked about a nocturnal district under the city in caves and caverns.
Wouldn't it be cool,
right?
Oh,
well there was no room,
right?
Say we gotta do we gotta do another one?
So,
but it's this,
there's the,
honestly the world is so big and the characters are so fun and compelling.
We could have gone any one of a hundred directions and had a really fun story.
And it's,
it's just like when you pitch these movies at,
uh,
at work where we work,
we work with about 800 people altogether on these films over a period of four or
five years.
And when you see a,
an idea start to light up and when you get the sort of the balance right and
people start to come up with ideas on their own,
they start to pitch you ideas.
That's when we really know that we have something that's going to work because
that's what the audience is going to do.
They're going to look at that and go,
oh,
wouldn't it be great?
And we see it on,
uh,
Twitter and Google and Facebook all the time.
Like with people kind of throwing in like,
did you guys ever think of this like fan art that comes in share with us.
It's so great.
It's amazing.
That's how we knew.
That's how we know that we're doing our job well.
You know,
when,
when we,
we began to engage with,
you know,
the audience and they began to,
their imagination starts to run wild and they're,
you know,
drawing pictures and sending them to,
and that
as a filmmaker,
that feels really,
really good.
Yeah,
we're very open.
I'm going to get the feeling from Google that you guys are like this too.
But we're very collaborative,
especially with these guys.
I mean when we bring in the voice talent,
we don't want them to just read off the page where we bring them in.
We ask them to be in these films because of who they are as uh,
not just their acting persona,
but who they are as human beings and the fact that they can ad Lib and bring
humor that we wouldn't expect or just court we're can't possibly generate on
around.
There's so much that like just these four right here brought to the film that
wasn't on the page and that's,
that's another layer of talent.
Where are they?
I mean they get to the point where they know the characters better than we do,
you know,
towards the end.
It's just,
we're just giving these guys a jumping off point.
Yeah.
You know,
to explore.
Yeah,
he just let him go.
And can you just talk about just your favorite scenes from the movie without
spoiling it?
Well,
I,
I do want to say to,
the film is absolutely phenomenal,
but the trailers don't show a lot of it,
which was phenomenal because I went to the film and thinking,
I was going to say one thing,
the slots thing is amazing.
And in the fall,
by the way,
this last 90 minutes of that,
it's 90 minutes of that low.
It just takes a great turn.
It's at a point and it's,
it's phenomenal.
It's completely different than what I thought I was going to get.
And it's,
it's a joy.
But what were,
what was your favorite scenes either do or just your scenes,
the scene that you saw,
the,
the final cut that you liked the most?
My favorite two scenes are the like mob scene.
Like a little,
uh,
yeah,
Mr big.
That kills me.
You guys will know what I'm talking about when you see it.
And my other favorite scene,
there's this,
when you get introduced to the world,
like you're talking about Clark,
it's the first time that,
um,
you know,
Judy hops is on a,
this awesome speeding train and the kick butts Shakira Song is blasting and her
headphones and it's just like you're seeing all the worlds that you just
described and it's just,
it's like Disney on,
I mean,
it's just the best at what you guys,
it's just unbelievably inventive and magical and something you've never seen.
And I was moved to tears when I first saw it.
It's JD Cory's easily,
you know,
I have to say.
So those are my two differ.
Um,
my,
my two favorites.
It would actually give too much away,
but I'll just say my,
my favorite two scenes were actually the ones that were the hardest for me to
record.
One of what?
One of which being a very emotional scene that was mentioned a few minutes ago.
Um,
because I am so used to being live on camera and having,
you know,
my face and my body and costumes and props and things to help express something.
And it was like not only am I just having to use my voice to convey this
emotion,
but I also add a point I think was blubbering and incomprehensible and they had
to like pull me back a bit so you could actually hear what I was saying and then
try to find a layer of comedy.
Trying to find a layer of comedy on top of that was something I hadn't really,
I don't know,
it was a balance I hadn't had to really strike before in anything.
Like I've either done,
I feel dramas or comedies.
I haven't really been in something that was such a Meld of those two genres.
And then another scene that was my favorite,
that was the hardest phone would totally be a giveaway.
But it's just,
it was,
it's one of those like famous Disney emotional punch in the gut scenes that
didn't actually involve as much of me as it was everything coming together.
Once you have the animation and the music and like it was just item it,
I'd give it,
but it's really good.
And they were you able to Improv a lot because you came from that?
That was,
you know that,
yeah,
that's my,
my background and that's what's cool is they kind of talked about it.
It's so amazing when you get in an environment where it is collaborative and
they actually,
I mean you guys they'd gotten the booth with,
with me out of it.
I don't know if that,
what was your experience,
but that's,
I mean I haven't done a ton of,
I've done two other actually series with TV or with a Disney animation wise,
but the coolness of like reading with them and being,
cause it's a,
it's kind of like prison in that way of it's a big glass wall.
And you know,
you have the,
the,
they're like great job,
you know,
like,
so,
so you can have a little bit of a disconnect sometimes as an actor in the voice
over,
but that they got in and,
uh,
you guys always were.
So there were times where I just kept talking forever.
I remember literally like I get them laughing and I'm like,
I'm just going to go for like three minutes.
Oh yeah.
We,
yeah,
we have that.
We have hours of evening hours.
No,
but I,
I will say specifically though,
one of the cool things it,
which is a scene where I'm with the cell phone with,
with,
with a gazelle where there's like a,
I don't,
yeah,
I don't want to give too much away,
but there ends up being,
um,
something where that was a little bit like that where we got to play in to see
it come to fruition and make it,
not that it's completely improvised,
but,
um,
but you,
you get to add a little bit to it.
And that's always a cool thing as an actor to get to do.
How about your timing?
Well,
you know,
I had a lot of experience doing Cheech and Chong albums,
alone who just Cheech nine,
the engineers.
So,
you know,
working with these guys with a piece of cake,
cause that's what we did a you,
we would get in front of a microphone and just have an engineer and then we
would just create with our imagination.
And so it was a easy,
and,
but when I saw the movie,
I mean I'm a big animated animation fan anyway,
you know,
cause,
uh,
in fact we used to,
I had a nightclub in Vancouver and we had a little party for a kids went,
you know,
my son,
my brother's a children,
had a birthday party and we showed I animated movies or cartoons and uh,
the kids where they watched it,
but it was the adults that really got it.
And so we used to close the club down on Sunday and put on the animation and
just laughed ourselves,
sick and then playing over and over and over again.
And so when I saw,
when I saw this,
it brought me right back to that world,
especially,
especially the,
their scenes.
There's wolves howling.
They're all my God.
I mean,
and there,
there are bits in this movie where I,
I'm,
I'm wanting to see,
I can't wait to see it again because I want to feel that,
that,
that humor and the humor in the industry,
like a lot of animation,
you know,
it's the humorous kind of hidden,
you know?
But this one,
it was out in the open.
It was so,
it was so crazy and so good.
And my character,
I was,
I just recovered.
In fact,
I came out of the hospital,
I had an operation and I came out of the hospital.
My son,
who was my manager,
he's a,
we got a voiceover Gig for you.
And I said,
what?
I literally got taken from the hospital in the car into,
into the recording booth and standing there and they're explaining the bit to
me,
you know?
But like I said,
I had all that experience with,
with teaching.
Jaxa was no problem,
you know,
say this.
Okay,
no problem.
We're really merciless where like you had surgery,
get in here,
come on.
I mean that was incredible.
Thank you for coming in those times.
I mean there it is.
Well and and uh,
with what I was most impressed with was right when the first kind of teaser
trailer came out with the walk cycles of all the animals.
So I kind of want to talk about what the technological hurdles where,
what this movie,
cause that blew my mind because each animal has their different walks cycle at
different 10 tendency and the animators really seemed like they were using all
those features.
Like there's a great scene that I saw when Judy hopps,
Jennifer's character was chasing after the weasel and it was,
she was bouncing off walls and stuff and the animals were doing a really good
job with that.
But just the animals.
I mean it had to be crazy to develop that.
And you guys also just had a lot of amazing software,
it seemed like with,
with fis grid Bonzai and x Gen.
So can you talk about just what was the next evolution in technology going into
this movie?
And
know,
maybe I could talk to him,
maybe one of these guys to talk about that a little bit.
Cause I'll talk about the animation part of it first because one of the things
that uh,
and you guys are probably like this to here,
when you get something that you're really passionate about and it's a project
then if it doesn't feel like work and that when you give our animators,
and we have about probably all like almost a hundred enemies in 1995 animators.
And so,
uh,
when you can give them something that they love,
the work does itself,
they will go to 150% on everything.
And what we ask them to do on this movie was to not forget that these are all
animals.
They're not men in costumes.
Don't think of them as guys walking around in suits.
And uh,
they studied every,
we have 64,
64 different species of mammal in this movie.
All different,
all with different rigs,
different body anatomy,
different for different clothing,
different scales.
We tried to be true to the scale of the animal.
So if a mouse is two inches tall and our world,
then it's two inches tall in Zootopia.
If a giraffe is 25 feet tall in our world standing on two legs,
same thing as utopia.
And so the animators geeked out,
they just said,
we're going to do this.
And so especially with Jennifer and Jason's characters,
the Fox and the rabbit,
they looked at hundreds and hundreds of hours of real fox footage in real rabbit
footage.
And you'll actually see Jennifer's character.
She almost gets stepped on by Rhinoceros in the movie.
And when she gets scared,
she goes back to the sort of primal instinct and this bunny behavior comes out
and she doesn't make very specific that bunnies to called [inaudible] look it
up.
You can Google it.
Yeah,
see I tidy guys said,
all right.
Anyway,
you can have you heard of this thing all the time.
Uh,
anyway,
somebody,
you can look up banking and you'll see
exactly what Jennifer's character does because of,
that's why we have these Geeky animators who love this stuff.
And if you give them a,
these projects and especially it's,
we've done it,
we've done a lot of films lately with human beings.
We'd done frozen and tangled and stuff and human beings are fine,
but it's nice to kind of mix it up once in a while and give them something new,
especially with this movie that had so much variety,
they just really got into it.
And do you guys want to talk about like the tech
well and,
and just the,
the ability to render the fur on the character,
the,
the looks of,
of them and the grooms.
Um,
and like you said since big hero six we have this Hyperion system.
It's a software that allows us just to output tremendous amounts of detail and
information per frame.
You know,
when,
when we render the film.
Um,
and so for the first time we were able to groom the character is not using like
a cheat,
you know,
on,
for not making it,
just this kind of stuff that looks kind of like human hair,
you know,
and I on bolt,
you guys could barely pull off the scene of,
of bolts that his head out of the car window and,
and,
and it was a pivotal scene in the movie and it almost didn't happen because the
tech department just to know how they were going to pull it off and it was only
seven years ago.
And now we have this system that,
that we can groom the characters with hundreds of thousands of individual pieces
of strands of for just that our model to look exactly like they do,
you know,
in the wild.
So,
um,
our,
our technology is just move forward leaps and bounds and in presenting a movie
like this.
Yeah.
And I think,
I mean,
just a couple of quick statistics.
So Jennifer's character has 2.6 million hairs on that rabbit,
9 million on a draft.
So that's a lie.
Everything want to go on to render.
But the most important thing is 9 million on a giraffe.
How many on Tommy's character do you know?
Tommy's is,
he's not even
wearing long clothes.
Yeah.
More of him losing his more exposed,
but 64 characters they studied each species for under a microscope,
discovered that at polar bears for is actually clear that a fox is first dark at
the root and it gets light as it goes to the tip that there are dreadlocks on a
JAKKS did,
uh,
you could have an oily kind of look on an otter so that every single for groom
is completely different.
Every animal is a different shape and size.
So we can't actually replicate those animals and just change the size of them
and make it different.
So you had 64 different models had to be created,
64 different rigs that had to be created.
Then we had to create shaders that would actually allow us to bring that,
have light,
reflect the fur and the correct way so that we as humans see it in the right
way.
And again with each type of Caribbean different,
the way that light reflects off of the fur is different.
So in every shot they have to think about that for each individual character.
And then we said the world had to feel alive.
So we needed plants and trees cause I was going to be the most way to make the
world feel organic and we needed that throughout.
So for us we had to go in and,
and get bonsai and look at the rain forest district in terms of the density of
all of the foliage that is in that one area.
And then on top of that we said we wanted to have there be movement cause in any
city there's movement.
So we had to create technology systems would allow us to move the leaves and the
branches on the trees and had the fur on the characters actually move in a way
that makes it feel again realistic.
So you keep adding on.
And then the last thing,
which is huge and you sort of take it for granted as you start to watch this
movie because the characters are walking out too.
But they all wear clothes.
So every single character has a different cloth simulation that has to be
figured out and they're different sizes.
So how does that skirt move on an elephant versus on a mouse?
Or how does the same thing for a t shirt move on to different types of
characters.
So four hours an intersect with for all those different kinds of firms.
So it was layer on pot on top of layer,
on top of layer,
and each decision was made individually based on what we thought was necessary
for the world.
But in the end,
when you look at all of it,
it was a little daunting.
But again,
as as Byron Image of said,
our team is so passionate about wanting to create great work that everybody goes
into what they know and they figure it out for you.
And it's a thing you just believe in.
And we're so lucky to get to work with these talented individuals who will go to
the ends of the earth to make it happen for you.
Yeah,
no,
it's,
it's phenomenal.
It's great to just see Disney eat,
you pushing these types of films.
And just not resting on your little laurels.
It's,
it's great.
Um,
so I'm bringing them to know from our Google photos team.
Uh,
yeah,
yeah.
Well,
What you gotta do it all right.
So I get the pleasure of talking about a couple of really fun things we got to
do between Google photos and the folks at Disney for this movie.
Um,
so we had a similar experience.
Byron is you had,
so when I found out we were going to be in Zootopia,
I went and found Sundar,
our CEO,
and I lifted him up and I put them up there like Simba that,
and I said,
we're going to be in some Topia make this a thing.
I know my did not go so well.
He's still not talking to me.
But anyway,
um,
it was,
it was just such a great experience when we found out about this movie and we
knew we have to be a part of it because I mean,
if there's a universal truth,
right?
Other than death and taxes,
it's this,
humans and animals both suck at managing their personal photos.
Right?
They take way too many slots to take way too many selfies.
Hippos always forget to take their phones out of their pocket when they have a
bath,
right?
So we knew we wanted to be part of this movie and be able to help with those
problems.
And so,
uh,
in addition to having a little clip in the movie,
which we really enjoyed our,
we also worked with Disney to create another sort of custom clip,
which we're going to show now.
Let's cue the video please.
Oh,
we all love our phones everyday.
We use our phones for this like all the time.
Can we take photos at every place,
every event,
and with every friend,
you know,
you don't want to lose those moments,
but hey,
things happen.
Phones break,
get your opt in.
Then
tomorrow's another day.
Good thing there's Google photos.
Your memories are automatically backed up.
Always organized the gang completely searchable.
Wait,
is that all your family?
Oh,
bunnies,
we are good at multiplying
soap.
No matter where you are,
you can view your photos anytime.
Well,
almost anytime.
Suga photos if you live in Zootopia,
but if you live anywhere else,
there's Google photos.
Disney,
Zootopia in theaters March 4th,
like a PG.
Oh,
nice.
All right.
So that was,
that was really fun.
And then the other thing we got to do is we actually got to go ahead and have a
little fun at the premiere.
So we got to go down to the Zootopia premier,
which was a couple of weeks ago down in La.
And we got to actually go down and do some fun things at the red carpet.
Now this was my,
personally,
I think this was my 32nd red carpet event.
33rd maybe.
Actually,
no,
I'm miscounting sorry.
This was my first one ever.
Wow.
And so it was pretty awesome,
right?
It was a really great experience that you guys were even so nice as to set me up
with a fake interview.
I really appreciate that.
I think this was the onion,
so I'm waiting for that article to come out.
Um,
but it was just a great experience.
And so once all US riff raff like me got off,
uh,
you know,
obviously the real talent came on and we want to have a little bit of fun.
So what we did is we set up an installation to take photos and so we went ahead
and took photos and Nate try to control yourself.
Shakira ne we,
we took,
we created an installation where we took photos from the vantage points of the
animals.
So here you've got,
what if we were in Zootopia,
we were taking a photo of Shakira,
what it would look like if we were Elian.
But what if we were a giraffe taking a photo of this event?
It will kind of like this,
right?
And you'd have that experience.
And of course this is what it would look like if it was a journal.
So not quite the full scope,
but we got to have a little bit of fun with it.
With this installation.
We got some great photos.
Of course,
of Shakira.
We,
um,
let's see here.
Who else?
We've got a,
here's Jennifer phone.
So this was a fun experience.
We didn't get to see the shoes as much.
The jural didn't get much there.
Uh,
we've got,
let's see.
Wow.
Okay.
The idiot squad siren,
right.
Is that your text by put the shoes.
Leopard tucks.
Tucks.
Let's be nice.
Kim.
Style payment is important.
We got,
we got nay nay.
It rains.
Those shooting down my shoes.
It was so rainy day.
Everyone was so,
it was not,
it was not good for that one.
Yeah.
Okay.
So this was the Jason,
oh,
we got some good photos of,
I think we could get Tommy to stand in one place for too long so we couldn't get
all three photos.
Uh,
and of course we had,
Katie is there,
there's Adam also that was bring your husband and workday to
uh,
and so it was a really great experience.
All these photos are up on Google photos,
uh,
so everyone can have a look and a and join the join the album.
But it was a great experience and we really appreciate the opportunity to be
part of it.
So thank you guys.
Thank you.
Awesome.
Linwood.
The audience questions.
If you guys want to head up to the MOH people are running.
Okay,
I have a chance to see it as a d 23 with my younger daughter.
She thought it was fantastic or clips from it.
And question I asked her,
I want to ask here cause I thought it was a great answer was I saw a lot of
things about unconscious bias in the clips that I saw and that's a big topic
here at Google.
Was that just you thought about or coincidentally had worked out of something
wrong with it.
Now
you know it's,
it's oddly timely this movie and you know it wasn't,
it didn't start that way.
But one of the things that came up when we were doing that year of research is
we found a very interesting fact about the mammal world and that's 90% of the
animals and the mammal world are prey animals and 10% are predators.
We actually say that in the movie.
One of the characters says that and we thought that's really interesting.
If you think about those two groups that are not equally balanced,
if they've really stepped into the future and put this eating thing behind them
a couple thousand years ago and figured evolved past it and they made this
incredible,
uh,
civilization did they completely put aside that mistrust of each other that
existed so long ago.
And that was one of the major kickoffs of what the story became and what
actually became the main issue between nick and Judy.
Like if you watch Jennifer and Jason's character,
that's what they're struggling with through this whole film.
And the fact that you see hopps who has this amazing frank capra s character
that has this beautiful core and wants to do something good in the world,
struggle with something that you didn't know existed within her,
it,
it made,
it gave the movie layers,
which I don't think anyone expected.
And it as we went through the story,
it kept building and building and building.
And we never set out to make preachy message movies.
We hate movies like that.
We want to just have people experience the films through the emotional journey
of characters.
And so that's what we really appreciate about what these guys gave us because
the natural performances and we have great writers and our Gr,
our recode director at Jared Bush and Phil Johnson who was his co screenwriter,
wrote a very smart script and we had to be very careful about what the movie was
saying and how it was saying it,
but it wasn't intentional.
But we're glad it happened and we're glad people are talking about it.
Yeah.
So I've seen the extended preview at Disneyland and that looks so good.
My family is so excited about it.
Um,
I had a question for Jennifer.
So you play snow white on once upon a time and you recently said that you go to
Disneyland every week.
Month.
Yeah,
once a month.
Once a month.
That's not healthy,
but I know the feeling.
It's a crazy.
Now do you ever pretend to be snow white when you're interacting with the
character?
I actually leave the,
um,
the snow white job to the ladies with the,
with the bobs and the like forties red and yellow dresses.
Um,
I actually,
because our audience for once upon a time are typically Disneyland goers.
We sometimes go in disguise because,
and I really love this Disney actually,
they,
they don't want us to cause a scene because they want there to be big.
Have you escorts.
Right.
Well and that they want,
but I feel like it's for such a cool reason.
It's not like a,
it's not like a Hollywood,
he reason it said they want the kids to,
to gather on Mickey mass and to gather around,
you know,
Winnie the Pooh and like those are the Disneyland celebrities and I respect that
so much.
Cause that's what I mean.
I could gather around them too.
And so,
uh,
so yeah,
so we usually like try and be a little incognito at the park.
Hi.
Um,
this question is for Tommy.
So I grew up like watching your movies and I saw you live in San Francisco about
seven or eight years ago.
It was amazing.
My laugh,
like I couldn't stop laughing in my face,
like hurt so bad afterwards.
Um,
so my question is how do you think your character is different from like the
Cheech and Chong movies to like this character now?
What was the question?
How was the,
how was this character that you're playing now a little bit different than when
you were in your Cheech and Chong?
Well,
uh,
not really.
I'm,
I'm a,
I'm a Yag.
That's the one,
it's the t shirt.
He doesn't wear the teeth naked.
What you saw was me
and our characters too.
You know,
we,
uh,
Cheech and I would find the most ridiculous,
weird characters that we could find that were real,
that everybody saw every,
every day.
And that's what the strength of this movie is that you,
you,
you know,
what this movie really did to me,
I mentioned it before,
is that it made me appreciate humans more because instead of having one view of
what a human should look like,
uh,
this movie showed you that humans come in all sizes and shapes and,
and beliefs and,
and,
and tribes and everything.
And it,
just,
that movie,
everybody fit in that movie.
There was a place for the hippos and their place for the draft and the place
where the little tiny people.
And so,
and that's what,
uh,
made Cheech and Chong so popular is that we,
we took real people,
you know,
we didn't have to invent anybody.
The people that we portrayed where,
you know,
our neighbors and people that we knew.
So it was a,
it was,
it wasn't a stretch at all for me.
Thank you.
So I,
the movie was fantastic but I also love all the more subtle call outs that were
in the movie.
Um,
some of them were settled like the carrot on the back of the phone or uh,
the Zuber or mouse card or that sort of idea.
And some of them were a lot more overt like,
uh,
the breaking bad stuff and the frozen jokes and so on.
How do you decide how to,
like how do you manage all of that?
Cause that's really,
for me as a viewer that's really dense and I have,
and I,
and I love it and I have no idea how you guys decide what to put in when you
decide to do it.
How that creativity comes about.
I find that,
well when,
when we're working in the story room,
we,
um,
we encourage all that stuff from,
from our story artists just from our writers,
just,
uh,
just lay it on thick,
you know,
it's like we had so many like puns for like,
or like joke signs for different,
you know,
a businesses that were animal ponds.
And I think it's the stuff that really makes us laugh,
you know,
are the ones that really make us grown the most,
or,
or whatever seems appropriate for the moment.
It's like,
then it's in,
you know,
there really isn't a formula or,
or,
um,
any specific recipe of doing it.
It's just,
um,
how much can we,
we just create tons of it,
you know,
just a tonnage of,
of this stuff,
you know,
and,
and just try to plug it in where,
where it's appropriate.
And then we,
we actually have to kind of manage it and make sure like,
is that,
is that one sign in that shot,
you know,
it should be there.
And somehow we,
we just kind of track it with our minds to,
and um,
it's after,
since doing this on shows like the Simpsons and Futurama,
it's like you Kinda,
you kinda becomes just kind of an innate,
you know,
a skill that you have in making one of these things that you want to make sure
that the whole thing,
if you can tell,
I mean,
after doing this for,
for awhile,
you can tell when it's starting to go off balance.
If you have too many,
if you don't have enough,
you know.
Um,
but it's,
and there's stuff that we don't even know about.
People kind of slip stuff in and put like license plates and uh,
if you watch the movie,
there's a flashback received nick as a little boy,
little,
a little fox,
like I can't,
I guess when he goes into,
he becomes a junior ranger scout and is true,
uh,
number is nine 14 and that's the birth date of the guy who did all the character
designs in the movie.
So it's all these little things or personal things or probably personal
birthdates there's in jokes about our own movies that you probably saw the
frozen jokes.
We've got those in there.
And it's great to have a world like that where you can actually do that and play
with it because the movie the begs for it really well because
the genre itself wants it.
It's a mirror image of like our world is,
you know,
the talking animal things are,
are that,
that's what it's all about.
That's kind of the main convention of this genre.
So as we were making the film it became obvious like it wanted more,
you know,
the story wanted more of this stuff,
and we,
we were happy to oblige.
Awesome.
Great.
I've got a question about um,
character creation process in particular.
I was curious,
do you pick an animal and then figured out what the personality is?
A,
do you have a personality in mind and pick an animal?
How did that kind of work when you antimony Puma finds people that way?
I guess we start with sort of the story need.
I guess we like,
uh,
the,
the sloths are a good example because we were,
we were kind of brainstorming a,
okay,
well what would animals do in this world?
And Jim Riordan whose jobs,
ups and stuff.
But what would be an interesting location if you need to go to yeah.
Like what are appropriate things for these animals to do?
And we have two heads of story.
Jim [inaudible],
Jim Riordan and Josie Trinidad,
both really brilliant people.
And Jim said,
well,
you know,
it's like a,
if it was a DMV,
it should be staffed by sloths.
And he just sort of set at this off the cuff and he was sort of like,
oh,
that's not gonna go anywhere.
And we're like,
oh wait,
wait,
wait a minute.
That's good.
Has that ever been done?
You know,
like somebody has to have done that.
We thought it was like,
no,
no one had ever done at Google.
And then I had to go chat.
Has anyone ever
wait a minute?
Did we just find something really,
really cool?
You know,
that that hasn't been done before.
And it's just kind of moments like that,
you know,
the Andrea and we tried to go,
that was the case of,
of going to type,
you know,
with the animal.
And then we would try to go against type for,
for others because we didn't want the world to be like a story book animal world
where,
you know,
they're all kind of doing their appropriate jobs and it's all very black and
white.
And uh,
we wanted it to,
to,
to be different shades of gray,
you know,
that like our worlds and you know,
that it was more complex than
then.
You know,
like a story book.
Yeah.
Talking to animal work and maybe the exception of some of that is that with the
lead characters,
the characters are really driving the story.
Like Judy and nick,
Judy,
we picked a rabbit because,
uh,
with these movies and with a,
when we need to root for someone,
you want them to be as much of the underdog as possible.
So the more obstacles we could put in her way,
including how cute she is,
she's teeny,
she's cute.
And uh,
there are female cops on the police force,
but they're all huge animals.
There's a huge elephant and there's a female polar bears and female tigers.
But Judy as a rabbit has this kind of ridiculous idea being this big tough cop
in this world.
And some more you got to go,
well that's ludicrous.
She's never going to accomplish that.
That's great for us because that gives Jason's character,
the cynic who grew up in Zootopia and has been sort of ground down by this
world,
able to kind of poke at her and kind of poke at that sort of frank capra
idealism that she has.
And it's great story fuel for us because if we don't have that conflict then
because in that case we'll,
we'll really think about that for a while because there were other people in the
story trusts,
we're poking at Nick's character like,
well shit,
he be a fox or should it be like a big tiger or something that's got more sort
of size contrast.
But what we liked about the foxes,
they have this great a sense of like cutting and sneakiness that you expect.
And Jason was perfect for that and they are,
the chemistry was great,
but then,
um,
you know,
we want want to,
to also keep a nick as a small Predator so that in those scenes there's a scene
where I'm Jennifer and Jason's characters are wedged between two huge polar bear
thugs in the back of a limousine and they're being driven off to be killed.
And that's great because you want that threat to be there cause the duo there,
they're underdogs as well,
you know?
Yeah.
I guess the rest of vague,
right.
It,
thank you so much for coming over and telling us about all of this.
And especially in bringing some of these other things that we won't get to see
in the movie.
And you obviously thought a lot about and thought a lot about creating and how
they interact with this world.
Do you feel like there are more stories that you can tell in this or are we
going to get a chance to see some of these kind of realized,
especially seeing how well,
uh,
as Utopia is doing in,
early reviews and things like that.
Lee's Clark,
but he's got good luck.
Luck.
Please,
please write to Clark.
Can we pick another one?
You know,
I always hope that that's where we can go.
We never think of,
but we'd never embark on a film thinking how can this be something with many
stories,
we're always focused on the mainstream because we have to ultimately create the
best story possible and hope the world falls in love with the characters and the
world.
But secretly,
the hard part is,
and it's at this moment in time where we all have to let go of this,
right?
It's going to go out into the world.
The world gets to see it.
But these characters that we've spent and,
and environments,
we've spent years building and creating,
okay.
Ent and it's always hard.
It's really an emotional thing to say goodbye to this cast and say goodbye to
our team.
Cause you know,
we work with 800 people and then suddenly we're just three people trying to
think of what's that next idea.
So it is always that kind of bittersweet moment,
but you do secretly kind of hope you can revisit those characters in the world
because we've had so much fun building it and this has been such an incredible
experience.
You guys in.
If we do another one,
so we count on you guys to Vancouver,
I'll go back.
I will say that we,
some of these stories,
I'll give you an example.
So the movie Clark and I worked on about seven years ago.
Bolt is sort of a closed ended story.
The dog and the girl are happy on the farm together in a sort of,
it's buttoned up,
nice and clean and you can walk away and kind of that story exists in that
little envelope.
Um,
this was built with so much potential.
I mean,
these guys,
oh,
I want him to spoil the end for you,
but there's so much potential of where you could go with the world.
And even the things we were talking about earlier,
things we couldn't include that are so much fun and so compelling that when you
mentioned them to people,
people go,
oh my God,
that would be great.
And then,
uh,
so,
the,
uh,
hopefully,
okay,
we'll see how it does when it goes out in the world.
But,
so I,
I would love to come back to this world sometimes.
Thank you.
Thank you guys so much.
Yeah,
I mean,
as he said,
it's,
it's getting,
you know,
critical praise and everyone loves it.
It's thing like a hundred percent on rotten tomatoes right now.
Like it's just,
it's crazy.
And just Disney seems to be,
you know,
hitting on all cylinders now and,
and in this new golden age and stuff,
it's just,
it's,
it's absolutely phenomenal.
You guys are just amazing.
So thank you guys so much for being here.
And,
uh,
Zootopia comes out March 4th,
so go see it.
So thank you guys so much.
Thank you.
Thank you guys.
Thank [inaudible].